und in düsseldorf begrüße ich den
präsidenten des deutschen reiseverbandes
norbert fiebig ich grüße sie herr liebig
guten morgen
es sind harte zeiten für die
reisebranche 80 prozent weniger umsatz
im letzten jahr sogar 90 prozent im
januar
was wäre denn in diesem jahr schon ein
erfolg für sie also wäre uns die
rahmenbedingungen ansehen dann wäre
schon ein erfolg wenn wir 50 prozent des
umsatzes machen würden den wir im
letzten normaljahr nicht corona jahr
2019 gemacht haben die verunsicherung
ist groß die rahmenbedingungen sind
nicht ideal fürs reisen dass die
quarantäne der regelung die dringend
ersetzt werden muss durch ein
schlüssiges testverfahren ist da und
führt zu verunsicherung was die leute
mehr und mehr in urlaubsstimmung oder in
die stimmung bringt ihren urlaubswunsch
entsprechend zu realisieren ist schon
die impfung aber jetzt viel zu langsam
voran im internationalen vergleich
denkmal hier katastrophal zurück hier
muss was passieren
in dem maße wie die impfung dann auch
platz greift in dem maße gibt es
sicherlich dann auch wieder mehr mut den
urlaub dann entsprechend auch zu buchen
damit sind wir schon beim thema denn die
politik bremst er eben ganz besonders
beim reisen eben weil das virus immer
mit im gepäck sein kann
was fordern sie denn konkret von der
bundesregierung wie kann sie ein licht
am ende des tunnels entzünden
also wir fordern dass die
rahmenbedingungen so gesetzt werden dass
da wo kein erhöhtes risiko vom reisen
ausgeht entsprechend dass auch
ermöglicht wird und nicht erschwert wird
und abgeschreckt wird sich quarantäne
regelung das robert koch institut die ja
nicht dem verdacht stehen hier nicht
neutral zu sein hat gerade in ihrem
letzten gutachten dargelegt dass die
organisierte reise nicht der treiber der
pandemie ist und das muss entsprechend
auch in den gesetzen rahmen der politik
berücksichtigung finden damit
entsprechend dann auch die urlaubs 5
die leute wollen verreisen wollen raus
die warten nur darauf dass das dann
entsprechend auch umgesetzt werden kann
die reiseveranstalter haben die übrigens
sehr deutlich seine rechnung getragen
sie haben sehr flexibilisiert
umbuchungs- und steuerungsmöglichkeiten
das zeigt jetzt erste früchte aber da
muss mehr passieren die quarantäne muss
weg das muss durch schlüssige
testverfahren ersetzt werden eine
quarantäne die heute ohnehin nicht
konferiert ist wird die sicherheit nicht
erhöhen aber entsprechend intelligentes
flächendeckendes testen wird dazu
beitragen die reise noch sicherer zu
machen wie gesagt robert koch institut
sagt die organisierte reise ist ohnehin
nicht der treiber
die leute wollen reisen sagen sie aber
doch viele menschen halten sich mit
buchungen zurückgeben weil sie nicht
einschätzen können wie sich die korona
lage weiter entwickelt 38 prozent wissen
einer studie zufolge noch nicht ob sie
dieses jahr überhaupt verreisen werden
wie wollen sie denn die zauderer unter
den reisewilligen überzeugen
ja die veranstalter sind da sehr kreativ
und auch wenn sie wollen entgegenkommt
sie haben die stornierung und um
berufsmöglichkeiten deutlich
liberalisiert so dass für den kunden der
jetzt eine buchung tätig bis kurz vor
antritt der reise kein finanzielles
risiko besteht wenn er sich dann dagegen
entscheidet aus welchen gründen auch
immer
und das neben mehr und mehr kunden auch
in anspruch das reisebüro ist ein sehr
guter berater hier kann dem einzelnen
aufgezeigt werden wie hoch die
flexibilität ist und dazu kann nicht nur
auffordern wenn sie den reisewunsch
angehen sehens 30 büro die werden sie
kompetent beraten was die bedingungen
sind und die sind sehr kundenfreundlich
im moment da sind sie immer im moment
noch etwas und einige veranstalter
wollen ja sogar ab den osterferien schon
wieder urlauber nach mallorca bringen
stichwort spanien schwer von der
pandemie getroffen andere reiseziele
haben davon profitiert profitieren noch
die türkei zum beispiel griechenland
auch kreta soll gerade stark nachgefragt
sein
er wird corona eigentlich den markt der
destinationen neu sortieren
auf lange sicht auf lange sicht auf
keinen fall im moment was wir stark in
der nachfrage gesehen immer noch auf
sehr niedrigen niveau für den sommer
2021 ist das östliche mittelmeer die
türkei und auch griechenland entwickeln
sich sehr gut
das östliche mittelmeer noch etwas
hinterher
wir werden keine verschiebungen sehen
wenn wir entsprechend unserer
reisefreiheit dann auch zurück haben und
die impfung spielt hier eine ganz große
rolle
dann werden sich die verkehre wieder so
verteilen aus meiner sicht wie sie das
vorher getan haben die leute wollen ans
mittelmeer rund ums mittelmeer und da
erwarte ich keine signifikanten
veränderungen in den buchungsverhalten
und was die wünsche angeht wo es in dem
einzelnen regen gehen soll
werfen wir noch einen blick auf den
sommer wenn hoffentlich wieder
grenzüberschreitendes reisen möglich
sein wird was raten sie den leuten die
ihren urlaub nicht auf balkonien
verbringen wollen wirklich jetzt schon
buchen und womöglich dann wieder
rechtsstreitigkeiten wegen annullierter
flüge riskieren davon hat es ja im
letzten sommer zuhauf gegeben
also ich rate dazu entscheiden sie sich
für eine pauschalreise die hat den
höchsten schutz sie haben einen
ansprechpartner und wie gesagt wenn die
regelungen so sind wie sie viele
veranstalter heute anbieten dann haben
sich auch ganz flexibel die möglichkeit
sich wieder von der buchung zu
verabschieden wenn es dafür gründe gibt
persönliche gründe gibt ohne jedes
problem können sie stornieren oder
umbuchen ohne dass sie einen
finanziellen schaden haben und der beste
berater dafür ist in der tat das
reisebüro das umfassend über die
bedingungen die jetzt sehr
kundenfreundlichen bedingungen flexiblen
bedingungen da auch beraten kann
in normalen zeiten wäre die empfehlung
wohl klar je früher gebucht desto besser
auch um frühbucherrabatte in anspruch zu
nehmen
wie ist das in diesem jahr wird man
dadurch weg günstiger wegkommen weil
kapazitäten geringer ausgelastet sind
wie wird er die preisentwicklung seien
im sommer
wie hoch der der mechanismus der
fotobücher weise der ist auch jetzt da
und es gibt sehr viele attraktive preise
im markt und das wird aus meiner sicht
auch so bleiben
ich glaube der der zeitpunkt der buchung
ist nicht das ganz entscheidende
aber es geht bei den frühbuchungen auch
immer darum sich das zu sichern was ich
denn genau haben möchte genau dieses
hotel und vielleicht auch genau dieses
zimmer zu genau diesem zeitpunkt und da
ist man gut beraten wenn man sich dass
unter den flexiblen bedingungen die ich
geschrieben habe vielleicht jetzt auch
frühzeitig sichern das klingt gut und
noch in der tat wollen wir den traum von
sommer sonne strand und meer nicht
aufgeben herbig ich danke ihnen für
dieses gespräch und größer nach
düsseldorf ich danke ihm alles gute